all right believe nation I'm a couple
minutes late for this live hangout why
because Wednesday is get a head day and
that is what I am doing I'm getting the
head on my new project the to 54 days of
confidence turned into a book and I just
got off a call with the team at Fanta
and we are we are making some serious
progress Wednesday is get ahead de get
ahead this is the project that I picked
I want my 254 series to be a book I
decided that almost a month ago maybe
three weeks ago it came out of the
suggestion from mark Drager from Fanta
and I said I love it let's make it
happen
December 6 we got to get it out two
years ago December 6 I launched your one
word last year of December 6 had
launched top 10 rules this year December
6 I want to launch the to 54 days of
confidence because the videos are
already having a massive impact it's
amazing everyday people writing in I
mean it's it's mind-blowing how much
people have gained confidence because of
that series here's my my struggle my
challenge when I'm trying to figure out
at the moment I want to blow the series
up I want a hundred different to fifty
fours you know the next one is gonna be
254 black excellence the one after
that's gonna be 254 for writers and I
wanted to be for everybody for all of
you like whatever your background is
whatever industry you're in whatever
you're struggling with I want to have a
254 around that because that is how you
change your habit the consistent
exposure to those ideas is how you
change the habit one time is not enough
it's the everyday if every day you're
around that you will change the
challenge is to make the video series
cost me 10,000 ish US per series so like
to make 254 videos for confidence takes
me about ten thousand dollars to do
which I think it's actually pretty cheap
but you know I can't go off and do a
hundred of them yet and I have no
business model behind them yet and so
I'm hoping the book becomes the business
model behind it that we make the videos
and then we have the book on top of it
and so Wednesday's get ahead day and I'm
getting ahead on this project and we're
gonna finish off the 254 so that it's
ready hopefully in the next couple weeks
cover design ISBN number
kind of stuff put it up on Amazon and
December 6 launch date so we'll see
we'll see how it goes
hopefully raises the money we need to
then go launch black Excellence Go Go
launch writers go launch girlboss and
launch whatever the one is it that you
want it is important to your life but
the message for today is get ahead like
just get ahead just get ahead on
something I think as entrepreneurs we're
struggling constantly because we're
behind we feel underwater we feel
there's too much happening we feel
there's too many responsibilities and
you end up doing a thousand different
things in a really mediocre way instead
of being awesome at something right and
I plan a day Wednesday for me is my
project day and that's the day that I
plan to get massively ahead on something
like it feels so good when you get ahead
on something it feels so good when you
take that thing that's off your list and
instead of doing it just for that week
like you're you're weeks ahead or you're
months ahead on that thing it feels
amazing and you start to build
self-confidence and you said to build
momentum instead of feeling like you're
drowning all the time now you feel like
you're massively ahead and it just it
just fuels everything else and so that's
what I want to encourage you to do
that's what I'm focused on I'm all in on
that today this is my this is my this is
my break my break besides going to the
washroom and even the washroom guys even
though I like I'm standing on my mini
trampoline with like with my legs
crossed been doing like the dance
because I don't want to go to the
bathroom because I want to I want to get
ahead when Z's get ahead day that's what
I want to do and so this this is my
break talk to you guys is my break and
then I'm back I'm back working on that
project and just I want you to feel
momentum it's so so so so so important I
want you to feel how good it is to be
ahead on a project instead of being
behind constantly and having self-doubt
constantly anyway that's not right for
the day also if you want to know what I
think and what other successful
entrepreneurs think about building
confidence check out my new 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 250 four days for free I will
send you a 30 second to five-minute
video in the morning to help you build
unstoppable confidence
the link is in the description below if
you want to be more confident you need
to surround yourself with things that
make you feel confident realizing that
any big endeavor is the collection of a
lot of small steps that came before if
you're doing work that you love you're
more likely to follow through you're
more likely to do it because it doesn't
feel like work because you love doing it
raise your standard Apple at the core
its core value is that we believe that
people with passion and not one drop of
most self-worth depends on your
acceptance a man if you want to learn
from Tony Robbins on how to create
massive confidence check out the video
right next to me I think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there all of us have kind of an identity
for ourselves a way of defining
ourselves and human beings don't usually
stray from that